[Music]
political corruption serves one not all
it subverts the very purpose of
government and creates distrust of
elected officials
corrupt politicians manipulate the
economy unfairly reward those loyal to
them and punish those who stand in their
way
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives four
historians discuss political corruption
in the modern world and they explain how
two former corrupt presidents got
punished for their deeds
we begin now with a look at two basic
types of corruption bribery and
gratuities
[Music]
the quintessential public corruption
offense is bribery
bribery is generally defined as a public
official agreeing to accept something of
personal value
in exchange for the performance of some
official act or exercise of official
discretion
a bribery presents a fundamental threat
to the proper functioning of our
political system
the bribed public official has a
conflict of interest he or she is
supposed to act for the good of all but
instead is acting for some private
benefit and this is contrary to the very
nature of a representative democracy and
corrupts our political institutions
title 18 section 201 of the u.s code
contains two distinct but related crimes
bribery and gratuities
to prove bribery prosecutors must prove
the following
a federal public official
corruptly
demands seeks receives or accepts or
agrees to receive or accept anything of
value
in exchange for being influenced in the
performance of an official act
or being induced to do or omit to do
and act in violation of his or her
official duty
or being influenced to commit or aid in
committing any fraud against the united
states
bribery is punishable by up to 15 years
in prison
along with substantial fines and
disqualification from holding any office
of honor trust or profit in the united
states
to prove an illegal gratuity
prosecutors must prove a federal public
official knowingly
demands seeks receives or accepts or
agrees to receive or accept anything of
value
for or because of any official act
performed or to be performed
by the public official
an illegal gratuity is a relatively
minor felony as federal felonies go it's
punishable by only up to two years in
prison
now the statute also prohibits the flip
side of both offenses just described
it's illegal to pay a bribe or gratuity
as well as to receive it
gilded age americans were greatly
troubled by abundant evidence that big
business was corrupting american
democracy
some of the most infamous political
corruption scandals took place in this
era
for example the credit mobilier scandal
was exposed in 1872
it involved massively inflated contracts
and shady stock deals related to the
building of the transcontinental
railroad the scandal implicated two
prominent congressmen and many officials
in the grant administration
in another outrage of the time the
treasury department and liquor
distillers were caught colluding in the
infamous whiskey ring this was an effort
to defraud the federal government of
excise taxes
but many many more corruption scandals
percolated at the state level
for example the pennsylvania railroad
enjoyed astonishing power in influence
in his home state during the 1870s and
1880s
the railroad actually had its own office
in the state capitol building and its
chief lobbyist was known as the 51st
senator
and there's actually a story that on one
occasion after a day of passing several
bills favorable to the pennsylvania
railroad a legislator rose and suggested
that if mr tom scott who was the
railroad's president had no further
business for the legislature to attend
to it ought to adjourn
in new york state jay gould's erie
railroad and vanderbilt's new york
central railroad competed for the
influence of the state state legislature
in albany by distributing vast sums of
bribery money
the role of corporate money in politics
was neatly summarized by republican
power broker mark hannah who said in the
1890s quote there are two things that
are important in politics the first is
money and i can't remember what the
second one is unquote
big business seemed to enjoy at least as
much influence in the judicial system
from the local courts and judges all the
way to the supreme court
legal decisions bearing on business in
the late 19th century overwhelmingly
favored business over the public at
large
including especially industrial workers
and farmers
so by the time we are picking up this
story in the late 1960s filipinos had
endured two decades of tumultuous
independence under a series of
presidents who kept promising economic
recovery land reform to help poor
farmers and punish greedy landlords
and peace to a nation wracked by peasant
rebellion and a communist guerilla
movement
ferdinand marcos won the presidency in
1965 by promising to end the country's
economic woes
but his opponents stymied many of his
plans and crime and unrest only got
worse
his communist enemies got bolder and
formed the new people's army to promote
the armed struggle for revolution
while a group called the moro national
liberation front began fighting for
independence for the philippines muslim
minority
marcos responded by trying to stamp out
dissent and declaring martial law
but gradually the regime became alarmed
at the way catholic-based communities
were becoming a lasting political
network for the opposition
after 1982 marcos stepped up arrests of
catholic workers
all this time the filipino middle class
who were mostly catholic were getting
angrier and angrier at all the greed
corruption and brutality of marcos and
his cronies
his wife imelda became world famous for
her collection of hundreds of pairs of
designer shoes
the last straw came when marcos henchman
murdered the main leader of the reform
movement a former senator named benino
aquino as he was getting off a plane at
the manila airport
the middle class revolted and joined the
radicals and mass demonstrations known
as the people power revolution
on the night of june 17
1972
five burglars broke into the
headquarters of the democratic national
committee located in the watergate
complex adjacent to potomac river in
washington d.c
initially
the burglary seemed of of little
importance
it was characterized by president
richard nixon's spokesman as a
third-rate crime
but the fbi's investigation soon found a
connection between the burglars and
president nixon's committee for the
re-election of the president
as investigators later discovered this
was the second time the burglars had
entered the dnc offices the first time
in may they went in to take photographs
of campaign documents
and to install listening devices
foam wire taps to monitor political
calls
but the wiretaps had failed
and they needed fixing
the june operation was a black bag job
to repair them
even after the connection to the
president's re-election campaign came to
light
at first the watergate break-in
looked like it would pass nixon by
five months later in november 1972 he
was re-elected in a landslide
in january 1973 the five burglars along
with two other republican operatives g
gordon liddy and e howard hunt
were convicted of conspiracy and
burglary
that seemed to draw a line under the
problem
perhaps the end of the scandal was near
then it spun out of control
one of the burglars wrote the presiding
judge john cerrika and alleged that
there had been a high level cover-up by
more senior officials
the burglar mccord also alleged that
witnesses had perjured themselves and
that the burglars had been pressured to
maintain their silence
a short while later
jeb magruder the deputy director of the
president's reelection committee
admitted to investigators that he had in
fact perjured himself and he implicated
two top nixon confidants in the scheme
john dean the chief lawyer in the white
house
and john mitchell who had been nixon's
attorney general until he resigned in
1972 to direct the committee to re-elect
the president
during live testimony in front of the
senate former white house deputy chief
of staff alexander butterfield revealed
the existence of a taping system in the
oval office
the disclosure shocked the nation and
altered the course of american history
of course
cox demanded the tapes so did the senate
but nixon refused to release them citing
his executive privilege
by unanimous decision on july 24 1974
the supreme court ordered that nixon
turned the tapes over
released to the public on august 5th
1974 the smoking gun tape was of a
meeting on june 23 1972 just six days
after the break-in happened
it revealed that contrary to his
protestations president nixon had been
part of the cover-up of the burglary
almost from the very beginning
the topic of the meeting was how the
participants could stop the fbi from
conducting the investigation
nixon's aide h.r haldeman began the
conversation quote
the democratic break-in thing
we're back to the in the problem area
because the fbi is not under control
because fbi director l patrick gray
doesn't exactly know how to control them
and they have their investigation is now
leading into some productive areas and
it goes in some directions we don't want
it to go
holdemon told nixon that the burglars
had been financed by the re-election
campaign and then offered a plan for how
to contain the investigation
quote
the way to handle this now is for us to
have walters the deputy director of the
cia call pat gray and just say stay the
hell out of this this is our business
here we don't want you to go any further
on it
end quote
nixon agreed again quoting all right
fine i understand it all he said and so
he gave the fateful order quote you call
them in good good deal play it tough
that's the way they play it and that's
the way we're going to play it
the tape and its public revelation meant
the end of nixon's political support in
congress and across the country
earlier as we said several congressmen
had voted against the articles of
impeachment in the house judiciary
committee
now
many of them publicly declared that they
would vote for impeachment on the house
floor
on august 7th the republican leaders in
the house and senate paid an evening
visit to nixon
they told him that impeachment was a
certainty and that no more than 15
senators would vote to acquit him during
the trial
and so just a day later on august 8th
1974
nixon announced his intention to resign
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here
[Music]